des poubelles qui peinent à être
débarrassé dans certains quartiers de
marseille depuis mardi soir pour une
troisième fois depuis septembre
syndicats éboueurs monte au créneau un
accord avait été conclu oralement le 20
décembre dernier avec la métropole mais
il n'est toujours pas respectée selon
l'arrangement question portait sur une
décote de 15% par rapport à la durée
légale du temps de travail et une prime
d'une centaine d'euros aux agents qui
travaillent le dimanche et la nuit ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui est inédit pour
pour la première fois on a une
administration qui a menti
un autre syndicat sa limite c'est pas
bien grave mais surtout qui a menti aux
salariés et c'est véritablement ça plus
que le non paiement de cette prime qui a
mis le feu aux poudres ils se sentent
méprisés ils se sentent humiliés et
c'est un avertissement que je voudrais
ici donnée la métropole qui ne
sous-estiment pas le niveau de
détermination des agents pour l'heure ce
mouvement concerne essentiellement les
collectes de nuit mais celle du jour
pourrait suivre si les rues principales
de marseille sont globalement propre les
poubelles des petites rues adjacentes au
centre ville commence à déborder juste
pour la salubrité de la ville ça c'est
assez dangereux pour la santé je pense à
long terme ça donne aussi une image un
peu sale de marseille qui a déjà je
pense à
une image déjà de base qui est un petit
peu problématique entre l'hygiène le coc
vident les poubelles tout ça
les entasse donc
je sais pas c'est la municipalité de
prendre des décisions pour sont
disponibles pour la négociation agents
et syndicats attendent un retour de la
métropole sur la situation